the nfl schedule release day it's really
a big deal people study it yeah and now
it's become like an event uh teams and
their fans finding out where and when
they're going to be playing for the next
season sports director chris matthews
joining us now in studio with more on
the raiders schedule chris yeah you get
your plans your tickets airfare all that
ready now it's becoming a big big day
for the nfl and its fans they now can
start making plans where will they go
will they wear coats or jackets maybe
not where will the raiders play well the
raiders will open their season on the
road september 11th at the chargers
it'll be a 125 kickoff right here on
channel 8. it'll be the eighth time the
two teams have opened their seasons
against each other now raiders home
opener is the following week at
allegiant stadium september 18th against
the arizona cardinals and again 125
kickoff right here on channel 8 your
network home for the las vegas raiders
hey we don't have to time to really run
through the entire schedule a few
breakout games though always kind of fun
and interesting here the raiders will
play one monday night game against
kansas city thursday against the rams
that is week 14 then the following week
it's december 18th sunday night here in
las vegas against the patriots on
christmas eve against the steelers the
raiders will visit the steel city prime
time game on nfl network while you can
catch out this entire schedule go to our
website eightnewsnow.com and check it
out by the way nine games possibly ten
will be here on channel eight this
season coming up in about 15 minutes
john treach is with raiders tight end
darren waller who is holding his
foundation fundraiser waller and some of
his raiders teammates what are they
saying about the schedule release back
over to you guys denise